all right getting the stream started
here we go right welcome
welcome back today we are going to
continue the discussion that we began
last time so if you recall
from last week we
started discussing consensus and in
particular we started talking about
paxos
and last thursday we spent a bunch of
time
going through the paxos algorithm
so we talked first just about a kind of
a simple
version of the algorithm that left out a
couple of the subtleties
and then we revised it to add back in
that subtlety
and so we looked at it in kind of this
two-step process where
first we looked at kind of the easy
version of the algorithm and then we
looked at a second uh iteration of it
that added a little bit more subtlety
particularly to deal
with a situation where we had more than
one proposer
so by the way i got the pedagogy that i
used there
where i talk about a simple version and
then a slightly more sophisticated
version
from a really great youtube video by
luis quesada torres
um about paxos so if you're
if you happen to see the announcement on
zulips or
if you happen to see the announcements
uh on zulip where i
link to that video i strongly recommend
it in case you
have any questions about paxos i think
it's a really good
introduction to paxos and i borrowed my
own pedagogy from that
video today we're going to
continue our discussion of paxos and
hopefully wrap it up
and if you recall at the kind of the end
of last time
we we started to get to this situation
where
we were talking about what happens if
you have more than one proposer
in a run of paxos and how do you end up
in a situation
where uh where proposers are kind of
fighting with each other so before i get
into that let me put up an agenda for
today
so we're going to
continue our discussion of paxos and
we're going to talk about
what i'll call dueling proposers
and this is going to lead in to the the
next thing that i want to talk about
uh which is called multipaxos
which sounds a bit scary but it's uh
it's actually
not too bad and then from there
we're going to talk a little bit about
fault tolerance in paxos
we're going to very briefly touch on
other consensus protocols
[Music]
we're not going to look at them in any
depth at all
but i want to make you aware that they
exist
and then one final topic that i want to
talk about
is what's called
passive versus active
replication
another name for this is state machine
and then i would like to spend a bit of
time talking about some assignment three
stuff at the end
this is a little bit unrelated to the
rest so we'll try to make time for like
10 minutes of this assignment three step
at the end
all right let's go so um
if you think back to last time we
started talking about a scenario where
we had a run of paxos and we had
two proposers so the way that i drew it
uh was and i think my black markers are
running really
low here we're getting to that point in
the quarter where the markers start to
run low
but we'll see how we do let's say that
we have two proposers p1 and p2
and three acceptors as usual
and let's say that we have something
like this so
[Music]
uh much like before um let's say
that we start things out with uh with
proposer one uh sending its prepare
messages
so recall from last time that the first
phase of paxos begins
with a proposer sending prepare messages
to a majority of acceptors
so let's just do it the way that we did
last time we sent prepare with a
proposal number
five we get some promises back
and meanwhile let's say we have this
other proposal over here
and let's say that it sends its own
prepare message
with a proposal number of six so let's
say that that one happens to go to
a2 and a3 so that'll do like so
this one will get back a promise
[Music]
oh what will happen here on a2 uh what
will a2 do
when it gets this prepare 6 message
think back to what we talked about
before
nobody really all right so yeah okay
yeah that's right it just promises six
because
what does a promise mean a promise means
that you're promising to ignore proposal
numbers
uh you're promising to ignore messages
that have a lower proposal number than
that well
it hasn't promised seven or anything
like that yet so it can go ahead and
promise six
that's right um
so then what happens over here on p1
well it's finished phase 1 of paxos
right here so now it wants to try to get
its proposal accepted it's received in
promise from a majority
of acceptors so now it wants to try to
get something
accepted so how is it going to do that
well it's going to send accept messages
and those are going to have the proposal
number that it got the
promise from the majority from and
whatever value it is that it wants to
try to get accepted so
no foo let's see
so then what happens well
on a1 it'll be fine
because a1 hasn't heard anything from p2
over here so a1 will accept
um but then what about a2 well a2
promised 6.
so what does that mean well it means
that a2 now has to ignore
any request with a proposal number lower
than six so a2 is just going to ignore
this request here so p1 you know it's
sitting here waiting
waiting to get responses from a majority
and it's sad because it doesn't get the
responses so it'll time out
and it'll try again so now maybe it's
going to try another higher proposal
number so let's say it sends a prepare
seven
and we'll come back to that in a second
okay what happens over here well
actually let's send the responses okay
so let's say that works and let's say
both a1 and a2 respond
with a promise
great okay well what happened over here
well p2
also got a promise from a majority of
acceptors so p2 thinks that
it can do can uh can try to get
its requests accepted now uh so
what is it going to do well maybe it's
going to say
well i want to get
the value of bar accepted
so it sends that out to everybody but
let's say that this accept message here
lands here
on a2 after a2 has already promised
seven
so now this one's going to respond
but now this one won't get a response
and so p2 will be sitting here and it'll
be sad
so what happened here well p1
and p2 both got through phase one just
fine
but then when they tried to send their
accept messages they couldn't get
a majority of the propos sorry of the
acceptors
on board with them to actually get the
value that they want to
achieve consensus on accepted by a
majority
and the reason why they couldn't is
because the other proposer who is here
keeps butting in with a new prepare
message with a higher proposal number
and gets there before it can so
this kind of scenario is what we call
dueling proposers
and you can probably see from looking at
this that this sort of thing could keep
on
happening forever the way that these
messages are being interleaved
we could keep on in this situation
forever where these uh two proposers
are never able to get a majority of
acceptors
to respond to their accept messages
and in this case they both happen to be
able to get a response from one acceptor
but one's not enough because a majority
here has to be two
so consensus is never reached because
there's no point where a majority of
acceptors
send accepted messages for a particular
value and proposal number
so here's a question for you
all this non-termination so this is this
could go on forever right we could run
forever and never reach consensus and
like we talked about before paxos indeed
violates that termination property that
we wish would be true
right that property that we want to have
be true of every consensus algorithm
so here's a question for you all of this
non-termination badness
seems to have come about because we had
two proposers right it came seems to
have come up because of
the result because we happen to have
these two proposers here multiple
proposers so
my question is why not just have one
proposer
why why have two
uh the question in chat was so because
of dueling proposers is that why paxos
violates termination
um so there's a lot of scenarios that
could lead to non-termination
um but they all kind of boil down to
this sort of situation in which a
particular
proposer is unable to get consensus
and in fact this isn't just true of
paxos this is true of consensus
algorithms in general
in particular it's true of consensus
algorithms
in a setting where uh
uh where the network is asynchronous and
where processes can crash
so this kind of thing and notice that
you know nobody did crash here
but nevertheless we can get into this
situation
so in in regards to this question of why
not just have one proposer
so so what do you think why why not why
can't we just have one
it's good to have options it's a
suggestion in chat
um somebody else says okay if there's
only one proposer then you aren't really
building consensus it's just one process
saying this is how it's going to be
yeah okay well right but when we drew
that consensus box
no and we tried to say you know here's
the inputs
here's the outputs i don't really care
how the consensus box works right like
i don't care if you know if one proposer
wants to declare itself the leader
and then tell the other tell the other
processes how it's going to be
then you know that's okay with me if
that gives us consensus then that's that
solves the consensus problem in the way
that we defined it but
there's a catch in what i just said
right i just said something about a
process declaring itself the leader
right so
yeah so what if
what if what if we what if we only
wanted to have one proposer well these
these processes come in right
and they're all equals at first right
they all come in here they all
they're all equals if we want
one of them to become the leader and we
want that one to
be able to tell everyone what to do then
we have to pick a leader
right and picking a leader
is itself a consensus problem
and leader election requires consensus
so
if you wanted to require there to be
exactly one proposer
and you tried to use paxos to figure out
who that should be
then paxos might not terminate right so
you can't require that there's only one
proposer because then your consensus
algorithm would depend on a consensus
algorithm
now as a matter of fact there are
consensus algorithms
and it's this is like not a not such an
unusual thing to do
there are consensus algorithms that have
a phase
that starts with electing a leader
electing one person to be the leader and
then that person gets to do all the
proposals
now that phase might not terminate
because leader election boils down to
consensus but then
if it does terminate then from then on
you're in good shape but you aren't
getting rid of the non-termination issue
you're kind of just pushing it into a
different part of the algorithm you're
kind of sweeping it under the rug in one
place
and then it can pop up again in another
so so we don't want
our consensus algorithm to depend on a
consensus algorithm and
and and that's the issue with the with
requiring that there's only one proposer
so leader election is kind of
interesting though right because
last time i mentioned that it it might
actually make sense for some consensus
protocols to choose
termination and validity right because
remember there's these three criteria
that we want we want termination
agreement and validity so what if you
chose
termination and validity as your
criteria instead of choosing agreement
and validity so paxos chooses agreement
and validity it sacrifices
termination what if you chose
termination and validity
and then you're sacrificing an agreement
so
leader election could be that right like
maybe you're okay
with actually having multiple leaders
chosen by your leader election protocol
as long as it terminates
so a thing you could actually do is use
a leader election protocol that doesn't
satisfy agreement
but does satisfy termination and
validity
use it to pick who should be the
proposer for a run of paxos
and if it happens to pick multiple uh
leaders sometimes then that's okay
because paxos still works when there are
multiple proposers
um and if your leader election protocol
picks a single node most of the time
then that's great
yeah if this makes your head explode
then you're not the only one
um but yeah this is dueling proposers so
this is basically an
illustration of a of a situation in
which paxos might not terminate
one way around this is to just have one
elected proposer
but if you do try to just elect one
proposer then that election process
itself
might not terminate so you can't really
get rid of the non-termination
possibility
it's going to show up one way or another
questions about that
ah there was another good point in chat
um so
right so somebody said so one reason why
you might not want there to just be one
proposer is
uh what if it dies right so fault
tolerance you don't want the only
proposer to die
and another good point is that maybe
maybe a new proposer shows up and
doesn't know there's already a proposer
right so you like your algorithm to be
robust to there being more than one
all right so this is kind of a good
lead-in to the next thing that i want to
talk about
actually which is called multipaxos
so we've been talking about using pexos
to decide on a single value
that's what paxos does you run paxos
it'll let you decide on one value
if you need to decide on another value
you have to run paxos again
and if you have to decide on another one
then you have to run it again right
and so if you have to decide on a whole
sequence of values then you have to run
paxos
again and again and again once for every
entry in that sequence
so what if you want to decide on more
than one value
it turns out deciding on a sequence of
values is a pretty common thing to want
to do
so if you think back to when i wrote
down a whole bunch
of uh of example problems that all kind
of boil down to consensus
one of those was this problem of totally
ordered broadcast
right so what's totally ordered
broadcast that's the problem of
making sure that a bunch of processes
all deliver the same messages in the
same order
so think back to our picture of a
violation of totally ordered delivery
right
where we had something that looked like
this
so this should be but whoops by now a
very familiar picture
so if you wanted totally ordered
broadcast well
we've got these two messages right
there's m1 and there's m2
so if you wanted to rule out this kind
of thing it boils down to
getting everybody to agree which of
these messages is supposed to come first
and which of these messages is supposed
to come second so that's really two
things that you have to
to achieve consensus on first everybody
has to agree to deliver
message one first and then everybody has
to agree to deliver message
message two second or maybe the other
way around maybe they all agree to
deliver him two first and then
m one second and then maybe there's a
third message that comes along and they
and then a fourth and they have to
choose uh
for those and so on so this is making
sure that a bunch of processes all
deliver the same messages in the same
order
so that's essentially repeated consensus
right
first decide what message is first then
decide what message is second then
decide what message is third
and so on
does anybody see any problems with
having to do that
oh there's a question from previously so
the question was
what is it because of dueling proposers
that we can't guarantee termination of
paxos i would actually i'd phrase it a
little differently
i would say that a situation like this
with dueling proposers
can arise in paxos but
the reason we can't guarantee
termination of paxos more generally
is that we can't guarantee termination
of any consensus algorithm
uh in an asynchronous distributed system
where uh where processes can crash and
so the reasons for that are quite
technical and so we're that would be the
flp results so we are we
i'm not going into details on that if
you want to you can check out the flp
paper that i cited earlier
but what i want to do is give an example
of how that
non-termination could manifest in paxos
and it turns out in paxos it manifests
and
it could manifest in this particularly
dramatic way
in which you have these proposers that
are fighting so
it's not a thing that's specific to
paxos it's actually true of any
consensus algorithm
but in paxos it can look like this
it's not always this dramatic
okay so back to multitaxes so
having to decide on a sequence of values
is something that comes up fairly often
and this question of totally ordered uh
broadcast uh or also known as atomic
broadcast where you have to get
everybody to agree what message to
deliver first what message delivers
second message to
deliver third so
what do you have to do then do you have
to run paxos every time you want to
decide
what slot a message goes in like do you
see any problems with doing that
a lot of work it's a lot of messages
right
even in the best case paxos takes a lot
of messages
because remember what the best case
looks like for paxis it's going to look
something like this
so you've got your proposer
and you've got your acceptors
you've got your proposer sending out
it's prepare messages
to majority getting promises back
then sending its accept messages out
and then getting those back so this is
the best
possible case right where
the proposer sends out its prepare
messages
gets promises back right away
then it sends out its accept messages
and then it gets those accepted right
away
but even in this best possible case
where nothing goes wrong
and nobody's slow when nobody crashed
and
there's no other proposer fighting with
you even in this best possible case
where
nothing bad happens it still takes two
round trips with the acceptors
to just get consensus on a single value
right
and that's slow
so is there anything that can be done to
make this better
if you have to get consensus on a
sequence of values
is there anything that you can do to
save time so that you don't have to go
through this whole rigmarole for every
single
value in the sequence of values any
thoughts on that
[Music]
okay so one suggestion in shot is you
could send the entire sequence in one
accept message
okay so you could batch things right
like if i have uh if i have
10 values that i need to get consensus
on i could try to just get consensus on
them all at once
yeah okay so that could help right
and that helps to some extent but what
if it's an infinite sequence right like
what if i'm just sending a whole bunch
of messages i mean i could batch them up
occasionally
and send those as a group um so that
would certainly that that could speed
things up
right on the other hand if you um
so that that would that would be good in
some ways and bad in others right like
uh if if you fail to achieve consensus
on that whole sequence
then um uh then that somehow seems worse
right
but is there anything else we can do
well so it turns out
that as we talked about before the
sopexus has two phases
right this is phase one
and this is phase two
it turns out that once you've done this
full run of the protocol phase one and
phase two
at this point you now have this majority
of acceptors
on board with you this proposer has this
majority of acceptors on board with her
and she can just keep on doing
phase two
as long as she doesn't crash so you can
just keep on deciding on more values
now that this proposer has done both
phases she can keep on doing phase two
again
and as long as she doesn't crash we're
in good shape
so you can keep on doing accept messages
with the same proposal number even so
that would look something like this and
i shouldn't have written on the bottom
of this diagram because i should have
left space to keep drawing but i'll
scoot it up like this
so let's say that these processes
continue
and proposer one can just do another
phase right
um so she can send another
set of accept messages out
maybe this time it's it's uh val two
that she wants to get consensus on
and if you want to you know you can
throw in um
like a sequence number here right you
can also add like another argument here
that's like you know sequence number two
uh that gets incremented um
and then they'll send back accepted
so it's just phase two over again
and it turns out this is safe to do
so if you're doing this if at any point
some other proposer comes along and they
decide to butt in
so you know p2 comes along
and they decide well you know i'm gonna
butt in here and i'm gonna send like you
know some higher
higher numbered uh proposal number
prepare
they can't right so if they start
sending proposals that are numbered n
plus one
right if they do this
then that's going to be the end of p1's
reign
right p1 will no longer be the queen
and if they manage to get a quorum of
acceptors on board with them
then no then p1 is done and and you know
one of her accept messages is going to
get ignored and
you know she'll time out and she'll have
to start over again you know the prepare
message so that'll
that'll mean that she'll have to end her
her um
her reign of having to of being able to
only do phase two
but until that happens until that
happens
she can just keep on doing phase two
and this is known as multipaxus
[Music]
and it's called multipaxos because you
can use it to decide on multiple values
a sequence of values
so another way to put this
when i say that somebody else can come
in here right
and and send a prepare message and sort
of interrupt the sequence
one way to one way to phrase that is
that to say that multipaxus
will degrade to just being regular plain
old paxos
if some other proposer comes along and
interrupts
but the hope is that that will happen
rarely
so i see now in chat i think somebody
said this well i was talking somebody
said yeah maybe the proposer could
repeat
phase two without having to do phase one
again and so that's it
so it's a nice optimization if you have
more than one value that you have to
decide on
once you've done a full run like this
you have to do that first there's no way
around having to do that to begin with
but once you've done that you can keep
on doing phase two only phase two to
decide on the rest of your values
until and unless somebody else comes
along and and
uh interrupts your your reign
you know i said i wasn't going to use
any of these parliamentary procedure
analogies but instead i'm using this
monarchy analogy
i don't know what that says about my
politics
so that's multipaxus it's basically the
scenario where
uh we can have this optimization if we
need to do
if we need to decide on a sequence of
values
questions about that and i i just want
to mention also that the suggestion that
somebody else made
of um of deciding uh on kind of several
values at once
of kind of you know cueing up several
things in the sequence and then sending
out
uh uh
an accept message with you know several
things at once that that's a good thing
to do
too and that's that's called batching
and you could do that as well that might
be another optimization that you might
want to do it would make sense in
certain
circumstances
so multipaxos is quite often how paxos
actually gets used in practice
because quite often agreeing on a
sequence of values is
the name of the game that's what you
want to do
well somebody just asked if there's
multiple proposers from the beginning
wouldn't this not work well
that's kind of um so there's kind of two
things here
one is that just because you have
multiple proposers doesn't mean that
they both have to be proposing things
all the time
right so paxos allows you to have
multiple proposers it doesn't require
you to have multiple proposers
right the ability to have multiple
proposers is something that pexa
supports
it won't go wrong right paxos won't go
wrong if you have multiple proposers you
could have 100 proposers and it still
won't go wrong
uh but and and if i go wrong i mean uh
it won't you know uh
it it uh it it will satisfy the
agreement property
right but um but it might not terminate
so but that's a problem anyway
oh this is a good question why do phase
one at all yeah why did we have to do
phase one
what would go wrong if we didn't do
that might be a fun one to think about
on your own
what's the point of phase one well phase
one is where you say i promise
what does promise n mean it means i
promise to ignore requests with a
proposal number less than this right
so if you skip phase one you skipped
making that promise
it might be useful to think on your own
about how things could go sideways if
you
if you don't do phase one
all right
so i think the next thing on our agenda
was that we wanted to talk about a
little bit about
fault tolerance
so i've been saying a few times
that consensus algorithms can't give you
all three of those properties you want
of of
um agreement validity and termination
but
that that can't possibly be the whole
story right because
here let me let me propose a consensus
protocol to you
have one acceptor
proposers propose values to the acceptor
acceptor picks one
broadcasts it to everybody done it meets
all the criteria
why can't we just do that
right fault tolerance exactly why can't
you have just one acceptor because it
might crash
[Applause]
so
we want to be able to withstand some
degree of processes crashing
so the actual and possibility result is
that you can't
provide all three of agreement validity
and termination
in the asynchronous network model and in
the crash
fault model and consensus protocols like
paxos
tend to be designed in a very i would
say what's called a defensive way
so that they'll be as robust as possible
to crashes that's why paxos is so
complex
so even though we can't get around that
impossibility result we can try our best
to make things work out most of the time
okay so we can't just have one acceptor
because it might crash
in my examples i've been using three
acceptors
how many of those can crash
how many of those can crash and we could
still run paxos
good yeah so one one could crash
if you have three acceptors what are the
what what do these requests have to do
well
if you send a prepare message you have
to hear back from a majority of
acceptors right so one of them could
have crashed and that's fine
you can tolerate one acceptor crashing
and still have the algorithm work
likewise with accept messages you have
to hear back from a majority
so if you have three one can crash
if you have five then two can crash
and so on so in general with pexos you
can tolerate a minority
of the acceptors crashing
so the way that this is sometimes
phrased
as somebody just uh noted in chat is
that
if f
[Music]
is the number
of crashes you have to tolerate
then two f plus one
is how many i should say acceptor
crashes
is how many acceptors you need
so that's acceptors
how about proposers how many of the
proposers can crash
well the question is why for five can we
only tolerate two crashing because
three is a majority there so we need to
be able to get a majority
right the proposers need to be able to
get a majority of the acceptors on board
with them
so if three crashed then they would only
ever be able to hear back from at most
two
so we can only tolerate two out of five
crashing
similarly with uh if you have three a
majority is two so one could crash and
you could still
make progress but not if more than that
right
okay so that's that's the deal with
acceptors what about proposers how many
proposers can crash well
all but one right yeah we only have to
have one so
if f is the number of proposers the
number of proposer failures that i want
to tolerate then i need f plus one
proposers so these numbers like two f
plus one you might hear bandied about a
lot when people are discussing
taxes so that's what they mean
so that's how pexos behaves under crash
faults it's not that bad right it's
reasonably fault tolerant
what about omission faults how does
pexos do under omission faults
well if i lose a message here and there
during a run of paxos
is it so bad
let's say that proposer one sent a
prepare message
and it tried to send it to a majority of
acceptors right so let's say it tried to
send it here
but then this message got lost for
whatever reason
so you know after a while you know maybe
it gets its promise
here and it'll be sitting here waiting
right
but is that so bad that's like to be
expected
right for one thing
it could just be that there's another
proposer out here who interfered right
so there could be another proposer who
came in and sent another message and so
uh got a2's attention before it could
respond
and so uh and so it had you know p1
doesn't know
what x what a two is doing as far as p1
knows the message got there and then got
ignored
right because another proposer uh was uh
intervening
so p1 totally expects this to happen
this is like a normal thing
so p1 will just be like okay whatever
i'll just send a higher numbered
proposal number
it's entirely normal in paxos for these
kinds of things to time out and so
if i lose a message here and there
during a run of paxos
maybe nothing will go wrong right
likewise if i sent this to all
of the acceptors and maybe you know
maybe this one tried to respond and then
that
got lost let's just say that got lost
but i only need to hear back from a
majority of them
so things could still work fine if some
messages get lost
if a message gets lost either you know
if i send this to all three
and a message just gets lost either on
the way or on
on the way back it can still work
and if all my messages get lost or if
you know a majority get lost if somebody
yanked out the network cable
right and so all the messages here get
lost what do i do
if i'm the proposer will i just send
another prepare message with a higher
proposal number
if i don't hear back after a while
so paxos does okay under omission faults
it might not terminate but then
it might not terminate anyway so
it's not so bad
questions about this
so one kind of useful thing to think
about here uh is that framework that i
sketched out before for thinking about
behavior
of an algorithm or a protocol under
different kinds of faults right so we
talked about how
we can talk about let's see safe and not
safe
and live and not live
for how a particular algorithm behaves
under a given class of faults
so well
with paxos we so termination is
aliveness property right so but we
didn't have termination anyway
even in the best case so so paxo
certainly isn't live
under these kinds of faults right um
but it's not going to tell you the wrong
thing right
so pexos does okay under omission faults
and that the worst thing that can happen
is like
it'll just keep running right and you
know maybe it'll take longer to get to
consensus than you'd hoped
maybe it'll even not terminate right but
that's just the you know how paxos is so
where does pexos fall in this picture if
we want to say
uh how does paxos behave under omission
faults well
it would it would have to go into this
category of safe but not live right and
we call this um
uh
what did i call it before did i call it
fail safe i forget
um there's different terminology
actually for that category but paxos
falls into that
class
in the sense that under omission faults
it's not going to do the wrong
thing it's not going to tell you i
achieved consensus when it didn't
right
and that's often the best you can hope
for
all right so i want to spend a very
short amount of time talking about other
consensus protocols
and we aren't going to talk about them
in detail
because my thinking is that
now that we've spent some time talking
about paxos
if you care about these other protocols
you should be pretty well equipped to go
out and study them on your own if you
want to
but i want to at least mention their
names
so
let me ask you first so some people were
actually talking about an alternative
consensus protocol
recently on zulip so what's an
alternative to paxos
right yeah so somebody just mentioned
draft so raft is kind of the
the one that's perhaps most famous these
days
but let me just mention a couple others
so
zab also known as
zookeeper atomic broadcast
is a consensus protocol
another one to know about is
view stamped replication
[Music]
so
i don't expect to go into the details on
any of these but i just want to give
some citations so you can go look them
up on your own if you want to so raft is
the most recently published of the bunch
um by
quite a few years so this was the work
of diego angaro
and john osterhout at stanford
and it was published in only 2014 so
this is
in recent memory and so this was uh
it actually took him a while to get this
published so this was work that
uh was happening in like 2012
2013 and i remember going
uh to a job interview in early 2014
where um raft was kind of the talk of
the town right then it hadn't been
published yet
but um the author the authors had posted
their draft online and they were kind of
shopping it around and
so people were there was a lot of buzz
around this concept of raft
so the deal with raft is that it's
intended to be
it's specifically intended to be easier
to understand than paxos
paxos is well known for being confusing
and the whole point of raft and of the
raft paper
is that it's supposed to be easy to
understand
part of the reason why it took them so
long to publish in fact is because
experts on consensus looked at it and
said there isn't anything new here
you're just
explaining it in a better way
and at this point you know you might say
that the consensus if you will of the
community
is that raft is very similar to the
consensus algorithms that have come
before
what's special about the raft work is
that they did a really really good job
of explaining it in a way that people
could understand
raft in particular owes
a deep debt to this work on view stamped
replication and this is
the work of brian oakey
and barbara liskov
uh from way back in 1988
so predating paxos in fact so
um some people who were experts on
consensus kind of looked at this raft
paper kind of squinted at it and thought
oh this looks a lot like this previous
work on view stamped replication isn't
it the same thing
and the answer is well okay more or less
yeah
but they did an extra great job of
explaining it and furthermore
the paper is actually so lucid that
you could pretty reasonably go and
implement raft
just from the paper so
emphasis on understandability here
so now it's like a rite of passage for
people who are interested in distributed
systems to go out and try to implement
raft based on the paper
uh it's a fun exercise to do if you
think consensus is cool
zab was published at some point in the
late 2000s
by researchers at yahoo research
whoops
2000s and this is part of zookeeper
so if you've never heard of zookeeper
zookeeper is uh is often used
for coordinating a cluster of machines
and so if you think about for example on
assignment 3
one of the things that we ask you to do
is implement this view mechanism
and the view mechanism exists to tell
all of the other machines who's up right
so the view is all about saying who's up
and and
uh who's awake that's one of the things
that in practice you would use a system
like zookeeper to do
so in practice you wouldn't necessarily
have to go implement the view mechanism
yourself because
you would be using some tool like
zookeeper to know that sort of
information
of course knowing who's up and who's
down again boils down to consensus
so doing it right having everybody agree
on who's up and who's down boils down to
this problem of consensus
now we aren't asking you to implement it
for your own view mechanism
yours is more like a best effort sort of
thing which is fine for the purposes of
our assignment
but really doing this right
is a consensus problem and so that's
what zab does it's the consensus
algorithm used by zookeeper clusters
and zookeeper is an open source project
that you can go
and and look at and inspect the
implementation of
um and they published this work as well
so
this is specific to the situation of
dealing with that
uh uh totally ordered broadcast or
atomic broadcast situation where you
have to decide on a sequence of values
to rule out those things like this so
that's why it's called zookeeper atomic
broadcast this is a synonym for totally
ordered broadcast
and that's what zap does
what all of these other consensus
protocols have in common actually
and i just said this about that but this
is actually true for all of them
they're all for achieving consensus on a
sequence of values
rather than just one
so like multipaxus
so wanting to get a consensus on a
sequence of values is such a common use
case for consensus
that that's what these other consensus
protocols bake in right from the start
so they're more like multipaxus and as
far as i understand it
they all also bake in leader election
as a fundamental part of the protocol
i think
so this is as opposed to paxos which
works with multiple proposers so you
aren't required to do leader election
with paxos
these ones do later election first which
may not terminate
but if it does then from then on that
leader that you picked
gets to be the proposer from then on
so if you look at the raft paper for
example you'll see that there's a leader
election phase
so there's a really nice paper that
compares and contrasts
different consensus protocols that i
just want to mention briefly
and as always you're not required to
read random papers that i mentioned in
class
the only ones that you were expected to
read are the ones that i actually assign
which is going to happen very soon but
this one might be a good one to look at
if you care about knowing about the
differences
between consensus protocols so it's
called
viva la deference if you'll excuse my
poor friend's pronunciation
by uh
by van rennis shipper
and schneider
and this came out in 2014
so this is a paper that looks at in
particular it looks at paxos it looks at
view stamped replication and it looks at
zab
and it compares and contrasts them and
it finds that
they all have a lot in common but they
also have differences
so no that's the best summary of it that
i can give is that these are all solving
the same problem
and so they're all kind of designed in
the same
uh in the same style
they they all are designed in the same
sort of defensive way
and you'll notice some commonalities
between them and so what these authors
try to do
is try to uh try to come up with a
kind of a clean description of what's
common and uh and what's not common
between these these different protocols
notice by the way this came out in 2014
and they didn't even talk about raft
so raft as i mentioned is has a lot in
common with vsr and if you read the raft
paper there's a discussion of that
all right i think that's good for
talking about alternative consensus
protocols
i think now is a good time to do our
quiz so let's do that and then
it's 4 21 right now so let's return it
for 31.
so here's our quiz question for today
there you go see you at 4 31.
you
right two minute warning
all right welcome back
so there's this uh disgusting discussion
happening in chat right now um
so uh patrick shared the raft logo which
looks like a raft so
i thought i might as well mention uh
why why is raft called raft well
you know we were just talking about how
raft is uh for deciding on a sequence of
values just like multipaxus and so
um it's for a situation where
you know you have some processes and
you're trying to decide what order to
deliver the messages in
and so you know this process gets this
message
and this process gets this message and
this one gets this one and this one gets
this one
and you're trying to keep the messages
from being delivered in the wrong order
so
the way all this could work is and i'll
illustrate this here with our pictures
that we usually do of our clients
and our replicas the way all this could
work is that you know
over here you have your raft
cluster uh where you have some
processes running raft and so
uh when replica one gets a message right
it needs to decide you know so this
maybe this is the message that's um
yeah forget that marker maybe this is
the
message that's trying to set x to three
maybe this is the one that's trying to
set x to four and what you want is for
these messages to land in these
places in this order what could happen
here
is that uh when a replica gets a message
like this
then it goes and tells the raft cluster
hey
i got a message um that says we should
set x to three
uh and meanwhile over here when r2 gets
this message it's going to say well i
got a message that says we should set x
to four
and so it'll talk to the raf cluster and
the wrath cluster will kind of you know
send a whole bunch of messages and talk
among itself
and you know blah blah blah and
proposers and leaders and
blah blah eventually it'll say
okay we're deciding on a sequence of
values here
and maybe the proposals for the first
slot
that we're trying to slot something into
these are the two proposals right
one proposal was x is three one proposal
is x is four
maybe the proposal x is four wins so
there's a slot here
kind of slot number
so slot number one x is four goes in
that slot and likewise over here
slot one x is four
and then there's another value in the
sequence that we have to decide on so
slot two
and of course i've omitted here a whole
bunch of back and forth messages
but the point is that you get this log
[Music]
on each of the replicas
that tells you what goes in slot one
what goes in slot two what goes in slot
three and so on
so what's the point of a raft well a
raft keeps the logs together right
so that's why i think it's called raft
all right on to our next topic
i know we were supposed to have a strict
uh ban on dad jokes in this course but i
had to include just that one
so the next thing i want to talk about
active versus passive replication
so
these are words that get bandied about a
lot and sometimes uh
get confused and sometimes you hear
people say really confusing things like
primary backup replication is active
replication and that's not necessarily
true
so what do these things mean so what is
active replication
active replication is when let's say
you've got a client
and so you've got some replicas and i'm
going to draw this like primary backup
where we have a primary and two backups
like this but none of this is specific
to primary backup
so in fact i'm also going to show
passive
replication with a primary backup setup
so don't conflate uh primary backup with
uh with active
but i'll get to that in a second so what
does active mean
active replication means that
you actually execute an operation
on every replica where you want it to
take effect
so let's say we had a replicated bank
account
um so let's say that
uh maybe the client does a deposit
of fifty dollars um
let's say that these all had 20 bucks to
begin with
um so what would happen here uh well
the primary would get this message what
happens in primary backup well it sends
it out
to everybody deposit 50
and they acknowledge
then their balance you know gets updated
and then finally the client gets
acknowledged
so this operation that deposits 50
actually got
sent to all of the replicas and
executed on all of them
alternatively you could do this
the client sends the message
the primary takes that operation
let's say it's 20 to begin with again
executes it on itself
and then sends a state update to
everybody else
so it tells them update your state to
70.
they say okay and then finally you
acknowledge
notice that these are both primary
backup
so why would you choose to do one or
these or the or the other
[Music]
let's say let's say active for example
when do you think that active
replication would be better than passive
replication
yeah okay so the suggestion in chat is
the state update could be
cheaper okay so that's one reason why
you might do passive right
so if this operation is expensive to do
then you might prefer to only do it
once right and then broadcast that state
update to everybody else
i use the word backups here but in
general
this isn't just used with uh with
primary backup replication so i happen
to be drawing this in a primary backup
sort of way
but in general this active versus
passive dichotomy
isn't just for primary backup in fact
you could draw a little
uh 2d grid my favorite thing
where you could have active
passive uh
primary backup and chain replication and
you could design a replication protocol
that fits in each one of these boxes
so this is a
orthogonal decision from whether you're
doing primary backup or chain
replication
so that's a good point yeah so passive
replication could be better
if this computation is expensive to do
you might choose to only do it once it
might be nice to only do it once and
then just tell everybody else what the
update was
so that's one reason why passive might
be better what about what about active
being better
is there any situation where you think
active would be better
hmm suggestion is choose active when you
don't care about time
i'm not sure what that means
and somebody just said reads versus
writes but both of these are rights
like the the read path is the same for
both of these the read path would just
go here
so there wouldn't be any difference
between active and passive in terms of
reads
hmm great point yeah
so one reason why you might not want to
do this passive approach
is if that state update is very large
right
if the state update is large then it
could take a whole lot of bandwidth to
send it over the network
what if instead of just depositing 50
what if the request i was making was
something like
um multiply the contents of everybody's
bank account
uh by by some factor and then update
everybody's bank account so then
if there are a million bank accounts
then the updated state
would have to be the updated uh the
updated balance of all those million
bank accounts
so you'd be sending this huge thing over
the network
right and so if you did passive you'd
have to send that huge state update over
the network whereas with active you
would just be sending
uh the operation that just said hey
update everybody's
uh bank account in this particular way
so active replication is better when the
updated state might be large
because sending that big state update
could take a lot of bandwidth
passive replication could be better if
the computation is expensive to do
so another reason also why you might uh
want passive is what if the operation
somehow depends on local process state
right
what if it does something like uh get a
random number from that process
right so you wouldn't want to do that in
an
active replication sort of way because
then every
replica involved might pick a different
random number and then you would end up
with even though you executed the same
operation on all of them
if it depends somehow on that local
state then
you'll end up with this non-terminic a
non-deterministic result where the
the processes don't agree so if the
operation is expensive or if it depends
on the local process state somehow
then passive is a good way to go if the
state update is going to be large then
active is a good way to go
so like everything else in this course
it's going to be a trade-off
i'm bringing this up now because active
replication
is a synonym for what's known as state
machine replication
and the idea of state machine
replication is that you have a whole
bunch of replicas
that all need to have the same
operations executed on them in the same
order
and therefore they go through the same
sequence of states
each of them carrying out the operations
locally
so you could accomplish this state
machine replication thing
using something like primary backup or
chain replication
with this active replication approach or
you could run a consensus protocol that
decides on a sequence of values
so that would be like this raft picture
that i drew here where we're keeping the
logs together
so this is also state machine
replication
in the sense that you have a bunch of
replicas they all need to have the same
operations executed on them in the same
order
they all need to go through the same
sequence of states in the same order so
one way to do state machine replication
is to use a consensus protocol like this
it doesn't have to be raft it could be
multipaxus it could be something else
but
that's one way to accomplish state
machine replication
and another way to accomplish it is
using something like primary backup or
chain replication
with this active replication approach
so that's what state machine replication
is all about and it's a pretty frequent
use case
of things like consensus protocols
so that's just something to think about
especially if you
if you look up the paxos made simple
paper it goes through the paxos protocol
and then at the end it shows this really
compelling application of paxos
which is in fact state machine
replication so
that's now you know what state machine
replication means and now you know not
to confuse it with passive replication
questions about any of that
oh there's some good discussion going on
in chat here about like various systems
and whether they
are active or passive and this is
interesting i don't know if we have time
to discuss it right now
because i want to get to the very last
thing on the agenda for today i want to
talk a little bit about assignment three
so assignment three stuff
i rarely talk about the nuts and bolts
of the assignments in class but i want
to do it this time
just because assignment 3 is hard and so
i want to try to alleviate confusion
okay so here's one thing i want to talk
about if you think back to when i talked
about
um uh different kinds of consistency we
talked about what's called read your
rights consistency
so what would be a violation of read
your rights consistency
that would be like if a client
sends an update
like this to a replica
gets it acknowledged
and then tries to read
and then isn't able to read her own
right
so if you look at the specification for
assignment 3 we talk about causal
consistency
in the spec and we talk about two
conditions that have to be true
to have causal consistency for the
purposes of the assignment
the first of those conditions and let me
actually bring up the spec
so that i can make sure that i get the
wording exactly right because i don't
want to lie to y'all
so the spec says
and i and i hope that i have an
up-to-date version of it here
yeah so the spec for assignment three uh
has
a couple of um
uh conditions in the definition of
causal consistency so let's just look at
one page here
and that they're they're here at the top
of page
five so it's the part where it says we
can now define causal consistency for
the purposes of this assignment
this first one where we say the effect
of a write operation by a client on a
key
will always be visible to a successive
read operation on key by the same client
that is read your rights so we didn't
put it here we didn't say this is called
you read your rights but that's what it
is
so this picture that i've drawn
um to come back to the picture
would be a violation of that property so
we want you to ensure read your rights
and notice that read your rights
uh is it you know we talked about this
notion where we have all
executions
and the executions that respect causal
consistency are going to be a subset of
read your rights
so read your rights executions
respecting read your rights are a subset
of causal consistency at least for the
purposes of assignment three
now one kind of interesting to think to
think about here
is how does this compare with the way
that we defined causal consistency in
class
so in class i said something like uh
when i tried to define causal
consistency in class
i gave a pretty standard definition
which was um something like
uh
rights that
have a causal order
are seen by all processes
in the same causal order
and this is like a pretty standard and
typical definition of causal consistency
but
you'll notice here that i just went
claiming that um
that causal consistency um subsumes
reads read your rights right because
there's this circle here of causal and
it's like fully contained in this circle
of executions that respect read your
rights
but this causal consistency definition
look at this execution here right this
execution that i said was a violation of
read your rights
if it's a violation of read your rights
and this is true then this ought to also
be a violation of causal consistency
but it's not really under this
definition here because the way that
i've written it out here
causal consistency has to do only with
the relationship between different
rights
and so it also has to do with reading
kind of in the sense where we say seen
by all processes but i say
rights that have a causal order and if
you're talking about the ordering of
rights then you're talking about there
being you know at least two
so this execution only contains one read
and um
or one right and one read so the reason
why i'm bringing this up is because
really what we want to do is we want to
think of causal consistency as being
this
plus read your rights and that is in
fact the way that we explained it
on the assignment spec that's that first
condition that we talked about i didn't
call it read your rights on there but
that's what it is
so we really want that to be true so
just in case
uh you were confused i mean we still
want this
and this is kind of you know at the core
of what most people think of call
of when they think of causal consistency
it starts to become very important as
soon as you have more than one right
um but we also want this ryw we also
want this read your rights thing to be
true
now how do you actually enforce this
well
as we say in the spec um in order to
enforce causal consistency
the client is going to have to be
involved right
so let's say that
this happens right let's say that the
client makes this uh makes this right
here to r1
gets an acknowledgement and then tries
to make this query over here
well maybe maybe our two thought that x
was two
before we what we don't want is for our
two to just sort of blithely respond
with two
we don't want it to be confident and
wrong in other words which is what
patrick would say
so how do we prevent it from being
confident and wrong well what's going to
have to happen
is r1 when it sends this response
it's going to have to send back that
causal metadata
that's going to say something
about the causal order of this operation
it's going to send back that causal
metadata with the acknowledgement
the client will get that causal metadata
and it'll pass it back
in the next request the causal metadata
will get here
and replica 2 will know i shouldn't just
respond with my old stale value it'll
see that causal metadata and no
i'm not supposed to just respond with
that i'm go i'm supposed to wait
until i find out from replica one
i'm running out of colors here but
sooner or later replica one is supposed
to send an update over here with the
actual update for
for x and at that point finally replica
2 can respond
with the correct
read your rights approved
value of x so that's what's going on
here
and this is this is something that
you're going to have to do all through
this assignment not just for read your
rights but all through the assignment
it's all about
getting that causal metadata and then
passing it back on the next request so
the client
has to participate in the propagation of
the causal metadata
and there's more details about that in
the assignment spec all right we're out
of time for today
so i'm going to conclude there we are
happy to ask
or we're happy to answer questions if
you have any
but we're out of time so i will see you
on thursday
oh sorry yeah patrick just reminded me
so
we uh we realized that there were a
couple of mistakes in the spec thanks to
students who pointed them out
so we are going to be posting if it
hasn't been posted already i haven't
checked but if it hasn't been posted
already we're going to be posting a
slight update
to the assignment spec that that fixes
some
issues and we'll post the diff as well
so you'll know exactly what changed
and um we're also going to be posting an
update to the
um to the test script that we shared and
in fact that update to the test script
has to do specifically with this
situation
so some of the time our test script
which is our test script is a client
right some of the time our test script
wasn't doing this it sometimes wasn't
passing the cause of
causal metadata back in subsequent
requests but it should be that's
behavior that you ought to be able to
expect of your client so
this shouldn't change anything for the
way you do things really
it's just we're uh we are updating the
test script so that we'll be more
well-behaved
so it'll be exactly the behavior that
you ought to be able to expect of
clients of your key value store
so we're not trying to make things
harder for you really we're trying to
make things easier for you
by ensuring that the test script is
acting like a well-behaved client
any quick questions about that before we
wrap up i'll check chat here
i don't see anything too much yeah
exactly so the question was clients will
send the causal metadata in gets as well
yes
yes yes yes they have to because this is
a get here
so you have to make sure to send the
causal metadata then too specifically so
that you don't violate read your rights
all right thanks everybody i will see
you on thursday